So once again recapping what we said. The sources of RPC latency are
the following. Marshaling and data copying. Context switches,
both at the client side and the server side. Similarly marshaling and
data copying also happens both in the client
side and the server side. And the actual protocol
processing in order to send the packet on
the wire. These are all the things that are
happening in software. Those are the things that
as OS designers, we have a chance to
do something about. And what we saw were
techniques that we can employ for each one of
those, reduce the number of copies, reduce the
number of context switches, and make the protocol
processing lean and mean so that the latency
involved in RPC is reduced to as minimum as
possible from the software side. And we are going
to take whatever the hardware gives us. If the
hardware gives us an ability to, to do DMA
from the client buffer, we'll use that but if it
doesn't, then we have to anchor that. So that's
what we are seeing here. As the opportunities for
reducing the total latency in going from the client
to the server and back to the client in RPC.